- Now, explain all
of this with regard
to the New York Jets.
(laughter)
- I desperately wanna
buy them, Larry.
- You do?
- Yes, I do.
- Why this, you're so level
headed and on top of things.
- [Gary] Yes.
- But sports things
are a fan thing.
You know look,
I'll tell you the truth.
When I came to America,
in Queens and in Dover,
I couldn't speak English.
Barely speaking any English
and they were playing football
and my friend
Eric Godfrey's like,
"What team do you like?"
And I was like literally that
kid that didn't speak English.
I was like,
probably did one of those.
And he says, "You're a Jets fan."
And so I went home,
I was like, "I'm a Jets fan."
It was my first American thing.
So they all had Jets jerseys,
we would play and I wanted
a Jets jersey 'cause I fell
in love with the Jets
but we were poor.
We couldn't afford
stuff like that.
It's not what immigrants do.
You don't go out and
buy a $30 Jets jersey.
So, my mom knitted me one.
She made it.
On the back of this it
has my favorite number,
number 5 and says Gary.
And I literally
wore it everyday.
It's my prized possession.
It's literally my
prized possession.
It just symbolizes
where we came from
which was very, very, very
humble beginnings.
And I've created
a fairy tale in my mind,
somewhere around
2nd or 3rd grade,
that I was gonna go from
not being able
to afford a jersey,
to owning the
whole damn thing.
Quest to buy the Jets
is my happiness.
Always wondered why
I always said
I would buy the Jets
and I wonder how much
all that has to do with it.
It's a big deal to me.
It's a big deal.